you've mentioned trust
quite a bit uh
you also mentioned trust minimization in
the chain link white paper
can we dig into trust a little bit more
what is the nature of trust that you
think about any smart contracts
what is trust minimization how do we
accomplish
achieve trust minimization sure
sure i i think it's important maybe to
have a conception of
of what the alternative is right what is
highly reliable trust minimized
off-chain and on-chain computation and
alternative to
so this is this is just kind of how i
how i see the world in these two in
these two camps
one camp is the traditional what i call
brand based
or paper guarantee camp and this is the
world as as pretty much most or all
people know it today
this is the world where there's a bank
logo or insurance company logo or some
kind of logo
there's a very big building with marble
arches and and columns you know it's the
biggest building in the town it's bigger
than the church
and everybody feels very good
everybody's got such a nice logo it's
such a big building
why don't i give them my my money why
don't i
i interact with them on the basis of any
kind of agreement
and that's good and that that is
definitely better than that
not being there and that is definitely a
huge improvement for how people
you know conduct commerce you know
letters of credit from
from branded entities are very important
for global trade to take place
in in the early stages of global trade
so
that's good but it is fundamentally just
a paper agreement
with the legal framework behind it and
if
the paper agreement you have would say
robin hood or somebody else suddenly has
to change
well it changes and you can't really do
anything about it you won't be able
to change anything about what happened
there there's some long term
service there's some other agreements
around all this stuff
at the end of the day um that's the
brand based
and paper guarantee world where it's all
very vague and opaque
and you're kind of hoping for the best
because there's a nice logo
it's been around 100 years there's a lot
of marble but a lot of marbles
big buildings lots of marbles this is
this is why banks have such nice
buildings right it's not because they
want to spend money on buildings
it's to create confidence in in them as
an entity
in order for people to transact through
them right this is why all these
kind of go to cities that had gold
rushes go to cities
that needed banking as as a service in
certain time periods
they're the most beautiful buildings at
least in the united states
so this is the brand-based paper
guarantee model
for which up until now there has never
been an alternative right so up until
now
if you had a bad experience with a bank
or insurance company or some
some logo somewhere you would only have
one option your option would be
to go across the road and down the block
to another
building with another color of marble
and another set of agreements that are
fundamentally still paper
brand agreements right now for the first
time
you have mathematical agreements you
have
mathematically guaranteed encryption um
secured decentralized
infrastructure-powered
agreements right this is um really
the shift this is really the comparison
and the alternative
through which people should view all of
this in my opinion because there's once
again this conception
that everything is fine everything works
very well
well it does it works fine and very well
as long as nothing goes wrong
and then in the cases when things go
wrong which they pretty much invariably
at some point do
then you find out that well you know
turns out they don't have to pay me or
turns out i can't trade or turns out
the atms can be locked up and only give
me 66 euros per day
whether i'm a business or an individual
like what happened in greece a few years
ago
right and the
the reality is that once that becomes a
strong enough
uh kind of realization for people i
think they will all just migrate to
mathematically guaranteed contracts
because why why wouldn't you so in
in the world of mathematically
guaranteed contracts kind of how do we
and cryptographically secured and
decentralized infrastructure powered how
do we how do we
evolve into that world well at the end
of the day
um it comes down to consensus right it
comes down to
an in a collection of independent nodes
a collection of
provably independent computing systems
arriving at the same conclusion
impartially that conclusion might be
the transaction is valid between
address a and address b address a has
one bitcoin
wants to send it to address b now just b
has one bitcoin right
so that's one degree of validation it
has certain cryptographic primitives
that are used certain levels of
cryptography encryption and other and
other methods that basically provide
um clarity and and those guarantees
but fundamentally it's this level of
consensus that multiple
independent computing systems came to
the same conclusion
verified that conclusion and created a
sense of finality
created a final state that is globally
considered to be
the state of a transaction
and that is how it's achieved right so
it's achieved by
users looking at these mathematical
contract systems
and saying you know if i have money in a
bank there's one single
person who controls that money that's
the bank they could choose to give me my
money or choose not to give me my money
and that's great but maybe there's a
percentage of what i own
that i want to put into another system
where there's thousands of independent
computing systems
that are promising me you know with the
help of cryptographic primitives
that i will be able to always have
access to this whatever this
is whatever this um you know token
is i will at least or at the very least
i will always have
unfettered complete control and access
to it
so you know that's one example another
example is hey we have a hybrid smart
contract for
something like crop insurance i as the
user
evaluate where this smart contract runs
oh wow the smart contract runs on
ethereum
great thousands of nodes lots of
computational uh
security hash power so on and so on
then i look at oh well what triggers the
contract oh there's this oracle network
okay it's composed of 25 nodes or 15
nodes gets data from five different
weather stations
you know i'm comfortable with that i
have a certain level of comfort
with that hybrid smart contract and its
ability to
provide me consensus about the
transaction
once the contract knows what's happened
and i'm comfortable with the consensus
around the event that controls the
contract right because once again that
event is what determines what happens
with the contract
and if the contract is super well
written it doesn't matter if the event
isn't reliable
right so now i've made this
determination i've gotten all this clear
clear transparent information about this
system that combines the contract code
with
a decentralized oracle network and i've
made my decision to participate in this
decentralized insurance
kind of crop insurance policy i've sent
the bitcoin or the stablecoin or
whatever i have on my
on my android phone and then time goes
by and let's say it doesn't rain
low and behold the smart contract uh
returns
the the relevant amount from the policy
back to me
i continue my life as as as a farmer
and by the way the fact that that
happened contributes reputation
and contributes proof back to both the
contract
as something that can prove to other
people that it has settled
and the oracle network as something that
can prove that it has
properly assessed reality or properly
triggered a contract
and this is where there's you know one
of many network effects where
the more that smart contracts and oracle
networks are used
they they themselves generate this
immutable unchained data
that proves their value and reliability
and improving more and more of that in
more and more
kind of use cases and more and more
variants of the same contract
they arrive at a greater body of proof
that they
like i am the decentralized crop the
decentralized insurance
contract for crop insurance used by
a million users and my failure rate is
non-existent or really low and here's my
oracle network and by the way
it's also settled a million of these and
so it's not the logo
right it's not hey what nice what a nice
logo you have
um on top of a building uh above
above a train terminal or something it's
much more
hey there's a million people there's a
million separate contracts that got
settled correctly i have
all the proof that i could ever need
about that
and it's it's not something that's very
easy to game right because real value
was at stake real value was
was moved around and so i i think once
again
the transparency aspect comes in where
you're able to prove
that the cryptographically enforced
contracts
are better that said you can still
integrate the traditional banks
as long as you create a data feed on the
model marble that's in
it that's included so if that's valuable
to you in terms of reputation you could
still integrate the marble the amount of
marble
that uh and the uh the size of the logo
we could still keep the banks around
like i think we will i think what will
happen with the banks and all the
insurance companies by the way
is not that they'll just die or
something i think it'll be just like the
internet
there'll be some of them that adopt this
yeah and some of them that don't
and some of them to do it faster some of
them to do it slower and and that's an
economic decision that they'll make
i think their whole question is is this
a foregone conclusion
i mean i think you know my answer my
answer is yes this is definitely going
to be happening
i think they still have a question of
you know is this going to change
my uh industry uh but i'm seeing
a definite shift in in people's
understanding
and i think that shift is going to
accelerate rapidly as one or two of them
of their competitors throw their hat in
the smart contract
ring and say well i have i have smart
contracts
i guarantee my outcomes to you what do
they do for you
you know it's risky just use mine and
the second some of them start losing
business because of that they're gonna
they're gonna move very quickly because
that's what all of their compensation
structures and
all their goal planning structures are
based around they're based around
what is losing us business or getting us
business yeah it's fascinating
organizationally though to think about
banks they're very old school
and their ability to move quickly is
questionable to me
i just look at basic uh online banking
like how good banks are creating a
frictionless online experience and not
and
i think they're not very good and so
that speaks to the kind of people who
are in leadership positions at banks
the kind of people they hire the kind of
culture there is
so i do wonder if banks will
from inside revolutionize themselves to
include smart contracts
or whether totally new competitors will
have to emerge
that basically create uh new kinds of
banks
whether what is the company's square
i think that's a it comes up out of
nowhere really
with cash app and they have bitcoin on
cash app whether they will start
incorporating smart contracts and they
will revolutionize
uh the the whole banking industry or
whether bank of america
will revolutionize themselves from
within i'm skeptical on bank of america
but uh you never know it's in general
i'm fascinated by how big
organizations whether it's google
microsoft or bank of america
pivot hard in a world that's quickly
changing
i think that takes bold leadership and a
lot of firing
and a lot of pain and a lot of meetings
where the one brings up
the from first principles idea that you
know what the ways we've been doing
stuff in the past
require you know we need to throw that
out and do stuff totally differently
i i i know a lot of those in in
in a lot of these different industries
um first of all i think they're getting
listened to more and and second of all i
think
all of these places as as i look at it
more and more
i think they have a fundamental line of
business that they try to protect
and then everybody's compensation and
everybody's metrics and goals is focused
around that line of business
so the second that
things begin to impact that then
everybody will be
in a senior meeting and and that
will be quite listened to
because he will have the only thoughtful
explanation as to why this is happening
how how things will evolve from there i
actually don't know because i you know
that hasn't
been the case yet but my my thinking is
that there will be people who
don't want to cannibalize certain parts
of their business or don't want to
change certain
parts of their business and then there
will be people who say
look i think this is how the world's
going to work we're going to make a very
very heavy
um kind of set of
commitments to to put resources towards
this um i already see that with with a
few banks
working working on various blockchain
based systems
but granted they've been working on
those for years so i i i think all of
this comes down to these these kind of
quarterly earnings calls where somebody
asks them
hey you know i saw that bank over there
launched a blockchain bond
or or a smart contract derivative
platform and i also saw that they made
you know 10 billion dollars in revenues
or or 10 billion dollars in volume or
whatever it is from from that
what's your plan right on the earnings
call
and i i promise you by the next earnings
call there's a plan
and then the question on the next one is
well when's the plan going to happen and
then by the next earnings
call it's uh plan is happening and and
that's that's that's what these people
are sensitive to that's what these
organizations are structured around
it it's not completely economically like
disconnected right they have this core
business they want to protect it
um i understand that that idea
but um i think the the problem with that
is sometimes it requires
it requires this myopic focus right and
and that's what all the innovation
stuff is about every time somebody at a
corporate entity is about
innovation they're they're trying to
sidestep this
but but once again the incentives to
maintain whatever the core business is
is so strong that the innovation people
even even though they they are there um
you know they get i think they get a
phone call and go like what are we doing
for this
and and and the ones that actually did
good work and got ready to do something
for this
have have done their you know their
employer and their organization
a very positive service whereas the ones
that aren't ready
i mean you know they'll make up
something and you know maybe they're
really smart and they'll get it together
i don't i don't know
you